hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com and in this
video I'm going to demonstrate how to
remove a Foley catheter on a female
patient so let's get started before you
remove a Foley catheter you want to make
sure that you have a doctor's order then
you want to confirm that you have
everything like the right patient the
right supplies and that you've explained
to the patient what you're going to be
doing and tell them that this is going
to be a simple procedure compared to the
insertion after you've done all that you
want to gather your supplies you're
going to need a syringe this is going to
be used to remove the water from the
balloon and you can find how much water
is in your balloon if you look on your
Foley catheter on one of the ports it'll
say like here it says it's a 14 French
and it has been inflated with 10 mL of
water you're also going to need several
pairs of clean gloves soap water
washcloths towels and a waterproof pad
because you're going to be providing
Perry care before and after removal I
graduated cylinder to empty the catheter
bag before room removal and several
alcohol prep pads to help you remove the
stat lock securement device and then
you'll want to perform hand hygiene and
Dawn clean gloves so before you actually
remove the Foley you'll want to empty
the Foley bag and there may be urine in
the Foley line and if there is what you
want to do is you just want gravity to
take that urine down into the back so
you can empty it and measure it so if
that's the case you can unhook your clip
if it's not clipped to the sheet and
then just gently take the tubing and
lift it and let it drain into the bag
until your line is clear so once you've
made sure the line is clear you want to
get all the urine in the bag so you can
unhook this part measure all the urine
in a graduated cylinder and then record
that in the output section now some of
it may be in this part of the bag so if
so just tip it back and then you can
empty it then once you've done that off
your gloves form hand hygiene and then
Don a new pair of clubs so before we
actually remove the Foley catheter I'm
going to provide Perry care and I'm
going to show you how to also provide
Foley catheter care so to do that I went
ahead and placed a waterproof pad under
the patient that's going to catch any
water and then I've had the patient get
in the dorsal recumbent position lying
on the back with the legs bent and
spread so it exposes the genitals try to
keep your patient covered up as much as
possible but giving you an area to work
just to help them not feel as exposed so
what we're going to do first before we
do care is we're going to remove this
securement device remove this device
you're going to need several alcohol
prep pads first what you want to do
before you actually remove this adhesive
is that you want to unclip this catheter
from the clip in the device so to do
this you're going to push the sides in
like that and it just pops off very easy
then we're just going to lift this up
carefully and just lay it right here and
it shouldn't move and it'll be safe and
secure there and then what we're going
to do is we're going to take our alcohol
prep and it tells you you hear on the
device removed with alcohol so you can
start on either side you want I'm going
to start right here so you can see it
and I'm going to get this wet with the
alcohol and what this does is it
neutralizes this adhesive that is on the
patient's skin so look it's already
starting to come up so we're going to
pull it up we're just going to keep
cleaning the skin and cleaning the
sticky part of the device and it just
easily comes up we're going to do the
same here and just pulling slightly here
as we clean the patch and the skin and
it just peels right off this is so much
more comfortable for your patient and
coming over here and just ripping it off
it could literally rip off that top
layer of skin so there came off now
you'll want to provide Perry care and
calf care before actually removing the
catheter and if you need to refresh on
how to do this I have a detailed video
on this topic if you click the card in
the top right corner now let's doff our
gloves perform hand hygiene and die on a
new pair of gloves now what we're going
to do is we're going to withdraw the
water that is in the balloon so we can
remove the Foley catheter itself we
would never want to remove this catheter
without withdrawing that water that's in
the bloom that would cause severe damage
to the urethra here we have a 10 mL
inflated balloon so I'm going to get a
10 Cc or ml syringe on new syringes you
need to pop the seal on it so just hold
it pull back on the plunger seals popped
and then just push it back in then what
you're going to do it's very very simple
you're going to connect this part into
the balloon part where you actually
instilled whenever you inflated it so
we're just going to connect like so and
notice I'm not pulling back on the
plunger it's pulling the water out
itself this is what you want it to do
you do not want to pull back on this
plunger that can change the shape of the
balloon and then whenever we go go to
remove it it could actually mess up the
urethra so we're going to let it remove
itself until it gets to 10 CC's and then
once it has got to 10 CC's we will
disconnect and this can take a few
seconds so it's now fully deflated I'm
disconnecting that so once we've done
that we're ready to remove this catheter
out and what we're going to do is we're
going to remove it out in one smooth
continuous motion we're going to have
the patient breathe in and out that
keeps the patient's mind on something
else plus that relaxes that urethra so
the patient breathes in and out on
exhale you are going to pull it should
be extremely easy just like that no
resistance should be met if there was
resistance that you felt you want to
stop and you want to make sure that
balloon is fully deflated and put back
on the port your syringe and see if you
have any water come out so this was very
easy and what we want to do is we just
want to inspect our catheter now we are
looking for any break of Integrity is it
all intact the balloon look okay or
balloon is right here and we're looking
for any weird growth or weird drainage
that could be on it if so notify the
doctor the doctor may want you to send
this to the lab get it cultured after
you have inspected everything you want
to take this just wrap it up in your
waterproof hat and dispose of everything
per the protocol so after you've done
that you can get your patient up go to
the bathroom if they're able they can do
Perry care again or you can assist them
with that you want to doff your gloves
and perform hand hygiene so once
everything's done this is your time to
provide education to the patient so one
you must tell the patient that they need
to tell you when they're going to void
next give them the call light it really
depends on your facility's protocol so
check it but they should void within the
next six hours if not you want to report
that to the physician and I like to have
the patient go ahead start getting up
within an hour to three hours afterwards
and just trying to void and this void
needs to be a complete stream that tells
us that's a complete void not just a
little dribble of urine now again if
they're unable to void within this time
notify the doctor you're probably going
to have to Bladder scan them to see if
there's any residual in the bladder and
see if they're retaining now whenever
they actually do void for that first
time you want to make sure it's not just
in the toilet you want to get one of
those measuring hats to put in the
toilet and you're going to measure that
first void and you're going to document
it so not only do you want to document
the amount and the output put it in your
nursing note and also talk about the
color and if you noted any odor some
things you want to tell the patient is
that the bladder and the urethra is
going to be irritated so urinating may
have a slight burning sensation but it
should decrease after a couple voids in
addition the patient may have frequent
air urges to go to the bathroom some
incontinent and issues starting a stream
at first but again this should go away
after a few times avoiding and if it
doesn't they need to let the nurse know
things that are not normal is that you
need to tell the patient to report
immediately if they develop a
temperature if they're completely unable
to void they have an odor to their urine
they have excessive bleeding or an
abnormal color and you want to provide
the patient with access to fresh water
because it's very important for them to
drink at least one cup of water every
two hours while they're awake to help
flush out that bladder and they want to
avoid any bladder irritants like
caffeine